hi everyone my name is sai venom with
the IBM cloud team today the topic on
everyone's minds I began and Red Hat now
our philosophy is straightforward
Red Hat works so let's keep it that way
this includes preserving their
independence their culture as well as
their commitment to open source now
we're in a very unique position here
we're seeing rapid growth of
applications being developed on the
cloud but that's linked with increasing
complexity the next chapter of cloud
computing is going to demand flexibility
and choice that choice starts from the
ground up when choosing the environments
to run or modernize your applications so
you can choose public or private clouds
or even on-premise environments building
on that we have the platform layer which
is supported by Red Hat's open source
technologies so we have Red Hat
Enterprise Linux as well as OpenShift
now this is powered by open source
technology and kubernetes so coming back
to choice if we wanted to use native
kubernetes over OpenShift that's also an
option building on that we have the
capabilities layer this is what
developers need to develop engaging new
applications so it could include things
like databases maybe their favourite
DevOps tool chains or even their
middleware platforms so for example we
know that for running j2ee application
developers may choose JBoss or websphere
liberty regardless of whether or not you
choose Red Hat or IBM technologies will
continue to support both fully as we
move forward finally all of this is
channeling our users to create new or
engaging applications by taking
advantage of higher value services this
is where IBM truly shines so these
include AI and machine learning
capabilities to summarize from the
ground up we have a hybrid multi cloud
platform where you can innovate anywhere
we have open source technologies that
Red Hat provides like open ship and Red
Hat Enterprise Linux all together with
their suite of technologies that
combined with IBM's
Mittman and expertise with enterprise as
well as our own Swedish technologies is
opening new doors to hybrid cloud though
we've never seen before
at the end of the day it all comes down
to an idea an idea that you build out
into an application an application built
on industry best practices and follows
security guidelines and compliances
because we want the same thing that you
do and that is happy users thanks for
joining me for this quick overview of
Red Hat and IBM synergy if you've liked
this video or have any comments be sure
to drop a like or a comment below and if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future please subscribe thank you